produced in partnership with Activision
who provided access to call of duty
World War two Savior woods a little bit
of this a little bit of that and I got a
friend with me here Bojo love it in the
building direct from e3 having a blast
checking out all of these wonderful
games and the latest in technology for
your home entertainment purposes we want
to get down we're about to get down call
of duty in our world war 2 we're about
to get in trenches on the ground
favorite charges throwing grenades and
see limbs fly what we want and that's
what they gave us
we wanted a real experience real boots
on the ground its back baby Call of Duty
World War two it's intense
basing the brotherhood and camaraderie
based on the European theater of war and
of course we'll be checking out war mode
once again and everybody's favorite team
deathmatch getting ridiculous it's
getting real it's getting real right now
okay there we go u.s. shovel I got
Colonel Klink let me know what's up what
up what's your name oh you'll know cuz
I'll be slaughtering you okay let's go
cross this bridge how you doing Joe you
good all right we building bridges
already don't worry about nothing
Oh God will go behind me okay alright
that's fine
bomb planet is about to blow nice nice
rally to the tank baby let's go just
keep moving the tank there we go oh
there's smoke everywhere my god I can't
see it can't see there we go
one head shot though oh so many kills
gonna come that kill Kingslayer kill
escort this tank baby let's go this is
what you want defender
defending this tank hundred points what
you want Daniel's match baby we got this
oh I get my shovel there it is I'm about
to shovel some fools I refuse to pull my
gun out until I shoveled somebody in the
baby I'm gonna win come to him catch his
shovel to shovel
[Music]
so far I still have my pride it doesn't
matter whether you win before you know a
little stop dude
awesome what's your favorite thing about
this new Call of Duty one thing that
cause we does right year after year that
when it comes to like gun feel and I
recoil that kick it's on point for me
the environments in the sound is that I
feel like makes a lot of a game feeling
like we're actually in these towns like
the way like you said the guns feel when
you see the grenades explode like the
blood lets it go everywhere and the map
design in this very balance whether
you're playing as a sniper
whether you're hip firing with a shotgun
there were areas and there in the
recorder to play
and Call of Duty World War 2 beta were
planted III but I can't wait to plant Oh
with his beta drops boots on the ground
we're out here
you